I love the relationship that you two
have on your your characters have on
television because it is it is so
original to me it is it's symbiotic and
abusive at the same time just like any
healthy relationship yeah it does really
feel like I mean you treat you treat
Tony's character horribly yeah he takes
it and he loves you back yeah yes I do
love it I know well she can it she can
be abusive to me but I just hear
chirping birds yes yeah it almost feels
like that's your acting technique Tony
is that when when you're being chewed
out
you don't seem bothered by it you almost
feel like you're not your character
isn't even hearing it no it's just it's
poetry to me and also like just hope
that because there was a season where
she was president and she wasn't as
close to me cuz she had a lot of
security and that's what I didn't want
as long as if she's she's abusive to me
that's fine as long as she's close to me
we're not weird to be on a talk show
together and lovely yeah don't touch
each other
you